happy New Year as we start 2023 I
thought we could look back at 2022 at
the developments in climate change both
the problem itself and what we're doing
about fixing it and I also have a quick
update about this YouTube channel this
video is also sponsored by curiosity
stream and nebula A lot happened last
year so I'm going to break events down
into two categories those relating to
the problem itself the physical system
of the atmosphere changing and those
relating to our solution to that problem
first of all the problem itself we had a
better understanding of climate change
at the end of the year than we did at
the start of the year with lots of
interesting important analysis being
performed and some Landmark papers being
published some of which I've already
talked about on this channel oh look at
that big back catalog the headline
Publications were of course from the
second and third working groups of the
sixth assessment report from the ipcc
covering the impacts and the potential
mitigation of climate change
respectively these reports summarize our
state of knowledge of climate change
with the bottom line being that the
natural world is already being
devastated by climate change with a mass
extinction underway and human
populations are also already being
affected and these impacts are occurring
due to still Rising emissions of
greenhouse gases that are highly
unevenly distributed but can be brought
down by increasingly low-cost
Technologies and effective policy in
other words we confirm that while the
problem is real and already wreaking
havoc our solutions to the problem are
becoming increasingly viable further
while most policy isn't in place yet we
have a good understanding of what
policies work well to implement
Solutions the most important solution
being the phase out of fossil fuel usage
more on that phrase later the working
group one part of the ipcc report made
it very clear that there is a strong
relationship between the amount of extra
carbon put into the atmosphere by humans
and the amount that the planet warms on
average however there are complications
to that relationship one of them was
examined in March in a paper that showed
the Amazon rainforest has been losing
resilience due to climate change and
deforestation meaning that it may be
approaching a critical transition or
Tipping Point considering the huge
amount of biomass present in the Amazon
any such transition dieback would have
Global consequences for climate as you'd
be removing a large carbon sink and so
atmospheric carbon concentrations would
rise faster as well of course as a
horrific loss of biodiversity and Amazon
dieback was one of many climate tipping
points considered in a big paper in
September which found that we have
already worn the planet by enough about
one degree Celsius to potentially
trigger some climate tipping points but
further that if we warned the planet by
one and a half degrees Celsius some of
those tipping points become likely I
talked about this in much more detail in
a previous video suffice to say it was
probably the scariest climate related
paper I've ever read as I just mentioned
the planet has warmed by about 1 degrees
Celsius the temperature anomaly for 22
22 specifically was actually 1.2 degrees
Celsius warmer than the pre-industrial
average that places 2022 as the fifth
warmest year on record with the record
holder still being 2016. for reasons
that will come to you at the end though
a study that came out this week found
that 2022 was the warmest year on record
for the oceans specifically yay buildup
of heat in the oceans is actually a
topic for a further video I think but
returning to the whole planet average
1.2 degrees Celsius is just that an
average some areas saw extreme heat far
beyond a 1.2 degree anomaly in 2022 with
12 European countries breaking
temperature records including the UK
which as part of the European Heat Wave
this summer saw temperatures of over 40
degrees Celsius for the first time since
records began as has been so frequently
the case throughout history though what
happened in Europe was dwarfed by what
happened in China specifically the heat
wave that took place in China between
June and August last year that I also
made a video about in brief it was the
worst heat wave in China since records
began and was perhaps the most extreme
heat wave in terms of intensity and area
affected ever recorded anywhere and it
occurred at the same time as devastating
floods in Pakistan that were again the
worst in the history of the country and
were partly exacerbated by climate
change these two events formed part of a
list of climate-related disasters last
year that individually cost over three
billion dollars for a total of nearly
170 billion but bear in mind that number
is just the sum of the top 10 costliest
events this alone would Place 2022 as
the most expensive year for climate
related disasters if the Christian Aid
methodology is the same as that of the
Swiss Ray Institute which I don't know
and they haven't published their
analysis for last year yet regardless
2022 fits in with a trend of rising
human costs associated with climate
change though of course we already knew
that thanks working group two so those
those were the big developments in the
problem now what did we do to try and
fix it the three big stories here were
cop27 the war in Ukraine and the
inflation reduction act the conference
of parties episode 27 the fossil fuels
Strike Back took place in Egypt last
year and
look some progress was made at cop27
even if it was perhaps more symbolic
than anything else the loss and damage
fund was the first time that developed
Nations have agreed to pay for climate
related damages in developing nations at
a cop
as they should but the details were not
thrashed out which means more delays in
a decade where we really can't afford
delays overall the conference was a
missed opportunity in a decade where we
really can't afford to miss
opportunities no progress on language
from the comparatively fantastic cop 26
with its phase down of coal the final
text of cop27 contained no references to
the completely necessary phase out of
fossil fuels as scientists and activists
have been calling for instead there was
just this weak reference to the phase
out of inefficient fossil fuel subsidies
and
that's it we had to hope that cop 28
this year will build on the successes of
the loss and damage fund and really turn
the screws on fossil fuel producers
let's hope that it's taking place in a
country that has ambitious green
leadership and wants to leave behind
fossil fuels as quickly as possible
where's it taking place
secondly I would be remiss to not
mention Putin's illegal invasion of
Ukraine last year as I covered in a
video at the time this has huge
repercussions for European energy with
an interesting contrast between short
and long time scales as a result of the
conflict the EU announced it was
removing its dependence on Russian
Natural Gas and energy more broadly so
far that has meant an increase in Coal
use in Europe being burned to make up
the energy shortfall so the conflict has
been bad for the climate on short time
scales but consider this by seeking to
improve energy security and Electrify
Heating and cooking systems the EU will
be investing heavily in renewable
electricity generation the International
Energy agency has described the
international response more broadly to
the Ukraine conflict as an historic
turning point that would lead to clean
air energy they predict investments in
renewable energy will climb to 2
trillion dollars a year by 2030. that's
a 50 increase from current levels
perhaps When Future historians look back
at 2022 they will identify Putin's
failed Invasion as a turning point in
the world's relationship with energy and
a real positive impact on our admission
of greenhouse gases
let's hope so and let's hope that this
conflict comes to an end soon with utter
failure for Putin the last big story was
Biden's inflation reduction act which
contained the most ambitious piece of
federal legislation to combat climate
change ever
could it have been more ambitious and
more effective absolutely yes but as
with Biden's presidency itself you've
kind of got to take the wins you're
given when you consider the Alternatives
despite its flaws a lack of ambition and
lack of regulations to curb fossil fuel
expansion the inflation reduction Act is
a significant I'd definitely say
historic step towards decarbonizing the
American economy boosting renewable
energy generation and lowering energy
costs for consumers insert obligatory
what if we make a better world for
nothing comic here but alongside this
action from the top down you can argue
that 2022 was defined by action from the
bottom up with the rise of groups like
just stop oil and insulate Britain as
well as stalwarts like Extinction
Rebellion using increasingly disruptive
tactics to generate media attention for
the issue of climate change and that
certainly worked but quite whether that
media attention translated into positive
action is Up For Debate personally I
think the climate crisis is absolutely
serious enough to Merit these methods
cross-reference the the first half of
this video but do you agree and do you
think that these methods resulted in net
positive action towards meaningful
change let me know down there in the
comments I think there's a very healthy
debate to be had here something to bear
in mind whilst you're commenting though
is that according to a report published
last year over the past decade an
environmental activist or an
environmental Defender has been killed
on average once every other day when
talking about just stop oil or
Extinction Rebellion we are talking
about a problem and people advocating
for a solution to that problem that is
literally life and death and not just
life and death in some future but for
some communities life and death now but
what about that future let's finish this
video with a look towards 2023. it is
very likely that 2023 will be a very
warm year though probably not the war
Mist the reason for that is that the El
Nino Southern oscillation or Enzo has
been in a cold or La Nina phase for
quite a while now for more on what that
means you can check out my video from
last month it's almost like I make these
for a living it is extremely likely that
enso will enter a neutral phase this
year which will be a significant bump to
global average temperatures compared to
2022 it is unlikely to be enough to
raise temperatures to those seen in 2016
though when a super El Nino event took
place but it will be an interesting and
Grim experiment to see just how high
they can go with the natural braking
effect of La Nina removed in May the wmo
estimated that there was a 50-50 chance
at the annual average global temperature
temporarily reaching one and a half
degrees Celsius above pre-industrial
levels for at least one of the next five
years compare that to the temperature
record to date
I don't think it's going to happen this
year but when the next El Nino phase of
Enzo occurs
yeah this is probably gonna happen so
does that mean that the quest to keep
warming below one and a half degrees is
dead well not based on this if we reach
one and a half degrees Celsius in the
next couple of years that will be an
anomalously warm warm year driven by
natural variability on top of
anthropogenic warming but regularly
reaching one and a half degrees Celsius
this century
unfortunately based on the events of the
past year I see it as all but inevitable
we are moving in the right direction the
estimates for Peak warming before 2100
are coming down last year the UN
estimated it to be between somewhere
between 2.1 and 2.4 degrees Celsius I
think based on the events of last year
that we will get that number down below
too things like the inflation production
act and Europe's response to the
invasion of Ukraine have given me hope
in that regard
but I don't think it's at all realistic
to say that we'll get it below 1.5
and that I want to be very clear is a
disaster the science tells us that every
tenth of a degree matters both in terms
of direct irreparable damage especially
to developing countries but also the
probability of reaching a climate
Tipping Point yes one and a half degrees
is just a round number and so arbitrary
but every tenth of a degree we reach
above it is still an increasing tragedy
and represents an escalating probability
of disaster we're moving in the right
direction but not fast enough to avoid
an unstable poorer more dangerous world
we can do better than this and frankly
we must lastly something a bit more
positive a quick update on this YouTube
channel in 2023 based on the successes
of last year and in particular the
successes of big high production value
videos like the history of global
warming by the way yes a sequel to that
is coming in the not too distant future
this year we're going to focus on making
slightly fewer but higher quality videos
we're aiming for about three a month one
of which will be some kind of big
feature
on this channel though this year I'm
also going to be making regular content
on my second Channel Simon Clark erata
there'll be a new DND campaign in space
on the RP Geeks Channel and fingers
crossed this will be the year that I
finally launch a big new YouTube channel
all about simulating atmospheres keep
your eyes peeled for that one that is a
lot to keep track of so if you would
like to receive a brief monthly email
summarizing everything that I've gotten
up to as well as some interesting papers
and articles that I found that month
then I just created a free newsletter
link to sign up to that is down in the
description also down there is a link to
sign up to nebula where you can watch
exclusive videos from me including an
analysis of the carbon footprint of a
famous adult streaming service the
search for Dark Matter down a mine and
extended interviews with researchers
this year would be a good time to sign
up for nebula because I hear there are
some big things coming sorry I've got a
problem with this eye of course you
don't just get extra videos from me on
nebula there are over 100 creators
making high quality thoughtful content
from current events to city planning to
film analysis you get access to videos
way earlier than on YouTube and without
any adverts whatsoever but most
importantly from our perspective by
signing up for and watching videos on
nebula you directly support us creators
revenue from the site is split between
creators based on watch time and a view
on nebula is worth significantly more to
us than a view on YouTube it's better
for us it's a better viewing experience
for you it's a win-win you can get
access to nebula at curiositystream.com
Simon Clark that's the link in the
description which also gives you access
to curiositystream the number one
resource for long-form professionally
produced documentaries on the web our
bundle deal saves you money 26 actually
and gives you access to the best of
Indie Productions on nebula as well as
those big scale Productions like the
power of fire and hour-long feature on
the science of droughts and wildfires on
curiosity stream as well as you know
thousands of other titles the bundle
works out to be just over a dollar a
month and it really is a win-win you get
access to a vast library of educational
content on both services and you get a
viewing experience that doesn't have
adverts interrupting you constantly and
we as creators get the revenue to make
bigger and better content sign up at
curiositystream.com Simon Clark with
thanks to curiositystream and nebula for
sponsoring this video thank you so much
for watching I hope that this was
informative and interesting and not too
depressing I know that it looks pretty
bleak at the moment and a lot of bad
things happened last year but if we
don't choose to focus on the positives
then we don't stand any chance of
pulling out of this nose dive lots more
videos about different Topics in earth
science coming out this year but for now
here's some videos I've already made if
you took something away from the video
please do pop it a like and let me know
in the comments your thoughts on
different types of climate activism that
just leads me to say thank you again for
watching and I'll see you in the next
one